[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas
eh bien oui ça va mieux mais quand va
mieux il ya plus de croissance
il ya moins de déficit il ya moins
d'impôts non mais monsieur le président
avec sept cent mille chômeurs de plus
pouvez pas le nier votre politique
intérieure c'est un échec
bon ainsi non s'ils n'ont pas ici si les
chiffres non c'était pas vrai si c'est
vrai je désolé non si non sinon si non
si celui qui dit qui y est j'ai raison
l'a connu plus un mais vous êtes pressée
parti voici votre première définition
gros lourdaud trop lourde jean luc
albert
la saison je m'appelle vallée riche et
raison je m'appelle josiane j'ai 36 ans
osasuna ce gros nigo
ouais
tu sais
jerry rice est sur le banc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]